Arianna,
I wanted to open up by talking a little
bit about the introduction to your book,
so you write about this collapse that
you suffered,
that really made you reevaluate your
life,
your priorities,
and I'm curious how mindfulness came out
of that because you write a lot about
health,
sleep,
exercise,
and you could have very well,
you know,
taken a vacation,
gotten some sleep,
and then moved on.
Why did you decide to stop and focus on
mindfulness as well?
For me,
this collapse eight years ago when I
collapsed,
literally from burnout,
sleep deprivation,
exhaustion,
hit my head on my desk,
broke my cheekbone and find myself
coming to in a pool of blood of my own.
I that,
that moment really made me reevaluate a
lot of my life.
And,
uh,
in the course of my life,
I had always been interested in
mindfulness,
in meditation.
My mother taught me to meditate when I
was 13,
living in Athens,
Greece.
That was quite exceptional at the time.
Um,
I went to India and comparative religion
before I went to college.
I've meditated on and off all my life,
so I've always been drawn to that aspect
of life who had changed eight years ago
is that I realized that I didn't want
this to be sort of episodic
journeys,
but to integrate them into my life on a
daily basis.
And um,
I started the science which is pretty
incontrovertible.
And,
and then I became fascinated with how
despite all that we know scientifically,
behaviorally how hard it is for us to
still change,
right?
And the,
and that's really a big part of thrives.
That how can we move from knowing what
is best for us to actually doing what is
best for us and to realize there are no
trade offs between leading and effective
live with what you produce,
results and,
and get stuff done.
And also being mindful and,
and taking care of that deeper dimension
of ourselves.
So when we talk about mindfulness today,
um,
how would you describe its main tenant?
So what do we mean when we say we need
our lives to be more mind?
I love actually what I'm John Kevin has
said about mindfulness,
which is that it's really heartfulness
as well as mindfulness.
It's really being fully present each
moment of our lives,
a mind and heart and body of cars.
And then what follows is that
recommendation that thoughts are going
to come,
you know,
we're not going to do star Bar,
but we don't really have to follow them
wherever they go.
And that's where for me,
breathing and consciously inhaling and
exhaling,
um,
is such an essential part of mindfulness
because I use my breath to return to
that centered place in us and let the
thoughts come and go instead of
following every thought,
sort of slavish Lee,
wherever it wants to go.
The other thing is that there has been,
as you know,
this avalanche of new scientific
discoveries that have validated ancient
wisdom.
So she lost her purse and spiritual
teachers have always known this things,
but now we have modern science
validating them.
For me,
some of the most important work is very
true.
Davidson at the University of Wisconsin
who is actually used modern methods like
Mris and lasers on,
uh,
on,
on the brains of Buddhist monks who've
meditated for years to see some
incredible results on the brain itself,
you know,
on gamma waves that show how that,
the plasticity of the brain is
extraordinary and we can actually affect
how our brain functions.
Um,
my being more mindful and taking time to
meditate and doing all these things.
In your book,
you refer a lot to steve jobs.
That's kind of someone who really took
this to heart,
um,
and managed to,
you know,
put,
put things like mindfulness ahead of
other things that people normally linked
to success and ended up succeeding more
so than almost anyone else.
In your mind,
is it possible to achieve that kind of
success?
We can call jobs a genius if you want.
Um,
without mindfulness,
is it actually an essential component or
is it something that you can take or
leave?
I think geniuses are so rare that I'm
sure there are many ways to be a genius
know by definition.
It does not conform to a standard
deviation.
So I'm talking about
all of us,
you know,
the rest of us who are not certified
junior says what makes for a life that
is both more meaningful,
um,
and uh,
and more effective.
I like to use that word because we all
want to be effective at whatever we are
doing for the vast majority of people we
know for certain,
um,
that mindfulness and Hans has everything
they enhanced performance.
Uh,
there is no trade off between being
mindful and being effective.
It also enhances our own experience of
life because if we just define live
purely in terms of success,
reduced to these two metrics of money
and power,
we're missing out on what for me is the
essence of life,
which you cannot really experience
without the third metric,
which is like the third leg of the store
in thrive.
I define it as consisting of these four
pillars,
well being,
wisdom,
wonder,
and giving.
And that's really what a complete life
is.
And very often we've seen people who
reach a level of success and then begin
to integrate a giving.
Our wonder by there it maybe too late to
integrate wellbeing because we now know
that tall that are around health and
immune system take if we live in in ways
that are consistently stressful and
wisdom,
which has to do with decision making.
Again,
I've caught a lot of people in the book
acknowledging like Bill Clinton,
who said that the most important
mistakes I made I made when I was tired.
So the connection between exhaustion,
sleep deprivation,
etc. And bad decisions is huge.